President Trump is daring Democrats to
draft articles of impeachment against
him saying he wants to go to trial he
downplayed the testimony of more than a
dozen witnesses during the house
impeachment inquiry over the past two
weeks and says the Republican Party has
never been more unified claiming
Democrats have no grounds to impeach him
the House Intelligence Committee will
spend Thanksgiving week writing a
detailed report of its findings before
turning over their case to the House
Judiciary Committee which will then
decide whether to move forward with
articles of impeachment Paula Reid is at
the White House with the latest Paula
good morning good morning Dana while the
president claims there is not enough
evidence to impeach him on CBS News has
learned that many White House officials
do we expect the house will impeach the
president and that's why earlier this
week they met with Republicans to talk
about what a Senate trial could look
like and how they may be able to shape
the process to help the president at a
White House event honoring college
athletes President Trump tried to appear
a beat about this week's impeachment
hearings despite some bombshell
testimony contradicting his denials of a
quid pro quo with Ukraine I think we had
a tremendous week with the hoax you know
the great hoax the hoax as a
presidential appointee I followed the
directions of the president but EU n
Bassett er Gordon Sandlin testified on
Wednesday that mr. Trump was behind the
efforts to pressure the Ukrainian
president to announce an investigation
into former Vice President Joe Biden and
his son hunter president Trump denied
that claim in an interview with Fox &
Friends
well that's total nonsense this guy
Sundlun hardly know him I've had a
couple of conversations with him I see
him hanging around you know when I go to
Europe the president also took issue
with top US Ukrainian diplomat David
Holmes who testified he overheard at
vasa der Sandlin speaking with the
president on a cell phone I then heard
president Trump ask so he's going to do
the investigation
ambassador songline replied that he's
going to do it adding the president
szalinski will do anything you ask him
to do I've been watching guys for 40
years ray phone calls and I can't hear
when you
you can be two feet away I can hear
people making calls I can't hear the
other side President Trump continues to
claim that Ukraine conspired to hurt his
presidential campaign in 2016 a theory
that has been debunked
don't forget Ukraine hated me they were
after me in the election they wanted
Hillary Clinton to win and CBS News has
confirmed that American intelligence
officials recently briefed senators that
Russia has been engaged in a year's long
campaign to frame Ukraine from Moscow's
own meddling in the 2016 election
intelligence chairman Adam Schiff says
he is open to holding additional
hearings but he doesn't want to hold up
all the proceedings for them but one
witness he is likely to want to hear
from is former national security adviser
John Bolton Bolton's attorney has teased
lawmakers that his client has details
that so far have not been revealed and
yesterday ambassador Bolton returned to
Twitter he told his followers to quote
stay tuned Michelle and a lot of people
are Paula thank you